Modern football is all about the numbers.
We've crunched the data,...
...ranked all of this year's hopefuls, and simulated the competition...
...to see which countries have the potential...
...to lift the World Cup in Russia this summer.
But how do you measure a country's potential for success?
Countries with a large supply of grassroots players tend to produce stronger teams.
Germany has over 16 million players,...
...the most of any country at the World Cup,..
...followed by Brazil.
Iceland is the outlier, with just over 32,000 players,...
...the smallest talent pool of any country in the tournament.
Star players make the difference.
Any team with Lionel Messi stands a chance of victory,...
...but the draw is key.
Even though Portugal have Cristiano Ronaldo...
...and are ranked much higher than Russia,...
...the hosts have a better chance of progressing thanks to an easy group,...
...not forgetting their home advantage.